one of the most interesting videos I've
ever seen actually is your Dogma like
artists
um the artists who drew like as the
world would look if you didn't have
glasses yeah right
um I remember seeing a video Once of
like a blind artist and he was born like
without eyes yeah and I was like one of
the most interesting videos I've ever
seen because this guy's an artist but
obviously he's never seen anything in
his life
um and he describes like what colors the
concept of colors of what he thinks
right and he's like oh I think I've seen
this yeah and he's like I don't get it
like people people have tried to
describe colors to me people have tried
to describe colors to me and it's such
an interesting concept of how do you
describe colors to someone who's never
seen colors please describe Orange
describe orange we'll see because we're
moving like imagine Heaven
it's the best fruit it's the best all
right
I think the general consensus because
yeah I remember seeing that video a
while back the general consensus is like
when you just uh when you talk about
things like the color red for example
right you think of like hot yeah or like
blue is like a cool color yeah but when
you think about it it's like that
doesn't mean anything yeah he's like so
people describe describe Rose as hot
it's like what the [ __ ] does that mean
yeah what does that mean why is hot a
color yeah
how the [ __ ] does that make sense
because like blue can be hot as well if
you're talking about a blue flame yeah
yeah exactly so it's like it doesn't
when you think about it it's like okay
how do you describe say like this
particular shade of purple to someone
it's trash days just trash chasing it
it's like oh of course of course I've
seen trash teeth but wait a minute wait
a minute I've heard trash days before
well so is these aren't good or what huh
is it good yeah yeah it's like it's
really cool I think I think it's I don't
know how does he know what he's drawing
I I think he's just I might learn am I
ignorant am I I think I think it comes
with that whole concept of like uh you
know if you're born blind or you're born
deaf yeah that is that is normal to that
person as it is for the rest of everyone
else who is born with sight or born with
hearing right yeah it's only I think I
remember like a comedian talking about
this it's only when normal people make
it weird that it becomes weird for them
right because like if someone is born
deaf then it's like well to them not
hearing anything is normal but it's not
until someone's like oh you're deaf oh
you can't can you can't hear music and
it's like don't make it [ __ ] weird
for them they're living fine I mean it's
like if I didn't know like document
existed it wouldn't bother me I wouldn't
know I didn't know it existed right
another when someone points it out music
existed I'd be like whatever dude yeah
exactly [ __ ] music exactly
but yeah like what's what what was what
I found so interesting is he can still
like he still can imagine let's say like
what a landscape looks like you know and
what how do you have your own
interpretation of what the description
could be or what you think it is yeah
yeah that would visual you could still
visualize that yeah like I think one of
honestly one of the coolest I'm gonna
call it ability even though it's like
kind of a condition because it it sounds
like a [ __ ] ability is I think it's
called like synesthesia or something
where you one sense is tied to another
yeah yeah right which is one which is
one of the coolest things I've ever
heard like I think uh we met uh Baron J
John who actually had synesthesia yeah
and like he was telling his story about
how you know you say a word or you hear
a sound and he sees like a certain color
with yourself yes and I'm like this is
this is like this is the closest we've
gone to like X-Men in real life wait
wait wait wait wait wait hold up so like
um
because let's say you said coffee to me
yeah obviously I'm going to picture
Brown
that's because you're associating it
with the object that exists yeah if
you're talking about say like a very
arbitrary concept that doesn't exist in
the Physical Realm and doesn't have a
form for example
God
I have an image like what color do you
imagine
uh you know why right but that's because
you're probably thinking uh
when you say God do you think light mode
uh yeah I guess so yeah
okay okay here's another example here's
another example when I say the number
three what color do you think of gray
why gray I don't know just thought of
that color what about number four
probably green why green though I don't
know it's green when you say color and
four I think green
like because of 420.
I don't think here's the thing I imagine
that it's like consistent right if they
if you always ask them for it would
always be the same color right if you
ask me four knit and then a color I I
would probably say a different color
every time right they seem like a
[ __ ] year okay so so I looked up on
Google for example right uh synesthesia
is when you for example you hear music
but you see shapes yeah uh or you hear a
word or a name and instantly see a color
uh for example you might hear the name
Alex and see green
yeah so do you have that or are you just
like no oh I think what you were doing
was just like hearing a number speaking
random color green yeah I'd say the
music one was a little sounds a little
familiar definitely seeing shape not
like visualizing shapes to music that
sounds familiar but not not the other
ones right right well then maybe you
might I feel like every music has like a
if you imagined do you know like if you
because it's like you know if you said
like rock in your head maybe you could
visualize what it would look like if you
were to
oh like rock music yeah well it depends
for me I think I think like yeah no
definitely like if you hear enough music
and you get into it then yeah you can
definitely start to like Envision like
I've had moments where I've listened to
a new piece of music and I can Envision
what the music video but I don't
actually see it right but I don't
physically see it yeah you physically
see it yeah you physically see it well
it's that's that's the condition that's
synesthesia that's that's so it's like
so it's like when you hear the word Alex
yeah your vision your vision because
that color and it's not only tied to
Vision as well I've heard of some people
where you it's tight like taste or
something so why would this be a
superpower it sounds like a detriment I
want [ __ ] shapes in front of my eyes
all the time well the [ __ ] I want shapes
you just [ __ ] with someone yeah if you
just see me like Alex Alex
are you sure this is what it is I don't
want to look it up yes it is a real
Condition it's one of the strangest
conditions I know I think of yeah I
think it's like super cool because it's
like it's because you see like you see
it clearly I'm pretty sure right yeah
well obviously I don't have something
well I don't know I don't know I've only
used when you said the music thing I
said I I feel that it's like I I didn't
you imagine that yeah yeah but no no you
physically see it yeah
yeah with like what font what Graphics
like what I don't know I don't know the
condition like like how would this look
this sounds what you should probably ask
someone with any any viewers watching
with synesthesia please explain in the
comments feel free to inform us
Enlighten us this is my ignorance of
where I'm like this sounds too fake this
I I think this is cool but like I I know
that's just because I can't because none
of you have it and none of you can sit
here
yeah it was like you're explaining it to
me and none of you have it so I'm like
this doesn't make any [ __ ] sense to
me oh yeah of course because I'm like I
can only I can only like imagine what
it's like but you know yeah I mean you
know I definitely can imagine things
like my mind can wonder when I listen to
a piece of music for example I think
anyone can do that but like physically
seeing something is very different huh
so you got it you got to be on some like
hallucinogenics exactly if you're a
normal person that doesn't have
synesthesia but for someone like this
it's like being on hallucinogenics all
the time okay so his WebMD only the best
sources yeah of course one of the most
common responses to seeing letters in
numbers and also colors you might also
see or hear a word and taste food see
here so like so like say for example
what but like not not but I don't think
it it's the word that is associated with
the taste so it's not the same as like
hearing the word bacon and then tasting
bacon it's more like a completely
different thing yes
let's say someone said bacon and they
might I would hear like be realistic
look at my yeah like that yeah maybe
or vice versa if I said free real estate
okay okay my ignorance on the subject
and might not understanding of it is not
one of like disgust or difficult I just
don't get it and I want to understand
because I think it's different to when
for example like you know if you see a
picture of a lemon then you start
salivating I think it's very different
to that because that is like an
association with priests that's that's
an association with pre-existing
knowledge of what that is but your brain
is [ __ ] weird enough where it could
easily make pre-existing bonds or ties
to stuff oh of course I mean again that
explains the whole thing of like looking
at a picture of a lemon and salivating
yeah yeah I suppose that's because I
remember they did that when I went to go
get a PCR test in Japan like at the PCR
Center they have pictures of like sour
plums and lemons there to help you
celebrate it
was really funny I saw this
right now the explanation makes it sound
like you like I I could believe it if
you
um you hear something and then it's a
very faint picture but like if it like
obstructing your view like what like I
don't know I don't know I want to know
I'm sure there's different levels of
severity to it maybe it's like a light
Hue or maybe it's just like putting a
piece of green paper in front of your
face I don't know honestly anyone since
the issue oh my God I'm not a [ __ ]
doctor if someone came with this [ __ ]
I'd be like all right [ __ ] off
[ __ ]
I shave this water bottle you see five
[ __ ] off you stupid come on my [ __ ]
office again
I can see yeah I can see as well I also
have eyesight
shout out to those doctors that just
like believe people
no I I I I know I mean to me it's like I
I want to know more about it because I
don't yeah it's is that like it's like
um a lot of the times I think that uh
like personally and uh our brains are
very poor at understanding things we
have no concept of being able to like
feel or experience ourselves yeah yeah
so like when I'm asking all these
questions it's not out of like it's not
real it's like it's just like I just I
just want to know exactly how it feels
and what you're experiencing yeah well I
think that's why it's so hard for us to
like say you know whenever you see any
kind of like charity movement or
something like that it's so hard to
convince people with like facts and
numbers but you hear like you hear a
story and you're like oh okay I get it
there is an issue there's a problem yeah
and it's not again I want to preface
this is not from like because I know
that this could be comparable to like
say mental health and it's like oh well
you know how could you say that you
could argue that doesn't exist because
you didn't feel it or you can't
empathize with it and that's not what
I'm trying to say it's that I it's not
that I I'm asking questions because I
don't believe or I don't necessarily uh
you know uh think it's real it's just
that I just want to know you want to get
because I want to feel like I can
understand and what exactly what it
feels like to have this thing it's
really fascinating as well because I
just said I'm just reading more of the
synesthesia thing on WebMD yeah not only
trusted sources uh the color it says
it's internal mostly the colors are just
in your mind only a few since
that uh see colors outside their body
okay see that's that's what I would
argue right because I how do you
determine that though because when I
hear music sometimes I can like assign
and feel and like if I would like I can
imagine like shapes yeah and stuff to
the music yeah yeah um because that's
just I don't know why but like
physically seeing it well outside
basically seeing it that's that's what I
thought you meant yeah apparently there
are some cases you understand that yeah
um but like yeah I feel like this is the
artist getting described to or like what
color is you know of course we're never
going to be able to like visualize that
because we've never experienced that so
we're like yeah I mean I get it but I
don't get it well because if that artist
had that symptom for example then it'll
be a lot easier
what color is red and it would just be
like oh number four and he's like oh I
get it all right but the reason why you
ask like a billion questions when
someone says oh I have this thing is
that you're like well okay well we're
not gonna just we need to make sure that
we figure out what it is that you you
have yeah so we're going to be very
thorough and ask every single question
explain it all to me there's something
not adding up there's something
happening and then you go and contradict
it again later by saying this x thing
it's like yeah I just want to know all
this stuff because I'm like I want to
just hear how it works because sometimes
you hear stuff and you're like that
sounds like you made it the [ __ ] yeah
what are your sources on that yeah yeah
well well you like it's an iPhone 12.
but also like the older you are the more
you realize man you're it's a brave the
brain is the brain is just [ __ ] weird